thank you pete and the team for putting
this together um i'm i'm so excited
about this and so my talk today um the
titles enterprise data science comes of
age and i uh in the abstract um there's
uh
there's a list of things that i wanted
to talk about i thought would be
interesting to
this audience and i do recognize that
this is uh
data council has much more of a data
engineering and data oriented
focus than maybe some of the more data
science and machine learning kinds of
things that i tend to frequent so i
wanted to really cover breadth of topics
um you know python where did python come
from how to get so popular uh why are
you guys having to fight dependencies
all the time isn't that on there okay
well um
ml ops i guess we call it now this
sounds cooler than fighting dependencies
um but then open source innovation how
that happens and what what does the
future hold for democratized ai right
now there's a lot of stuff and they all
sort of like interconnect with each
other so to frame it better i thought i
would use a more familiar uh backbone to
tell the story and if you guys have ever
heard of this thing called star wars you
sort of start with um like all great
stories start with episode four where a
new language emerges in the scene for
data data processing and whatnot um and
then as it gets enterprise adoption
right how does it have to change what
does it mean when enterprises really
start adopting your technology and then
lastly um what does the future look like
and just to give it away a little bit i
think the future we're heading into is a
cybernetic one
and what does that mean like is that
like just a bad sci-fi movie trip or
like what does cybernetics really mean
for us i thought it was about ai right
so this is gonna be the structure of the
talk
um and so of course you can't do star
wars without doing a little bit of a
text call i don't think you guys see
that in the back um but it's it's really
funny i assure you at least when i wrote
at 1am it was really funny um but the
general concept here is that when we
started a lot of the stuff uh pushing
python for data um and as pete mentioned
um you know the pi data stuff we started
getting all this going about 10 years
ago it was kind of a rebel thing it was
like this weird thing it's like python i
thought that was the ruby alternative um
you know obviously hadoop and r and
these are the things that are going to
be the future of data um and and me and
a few other people were like no python's
kind of a thing so
um this this first section episode four
is how did python actually take over how
did it actually come to mass so back in
2012 i had this thesis that there was a
double disruption happening in the well
industry broadly as a term but really in
business and technical computing and
technical computing is the term as
euphemism that's used instead of
scientific computing because no vcs will
find anything of the word science in
them so
really the the concept here is if you
really care about performance if you
care about linear algebra it sort of
goes under technical computing um and
then business is you know cares about
sql so i saw a double disruption
happening in these spaces so i saw that
the big data wave that was happening was
was transforming
um
transforming how traditional data
warehouses worked right the ralph
kimball stuff the enterprise data
warehouse stuff that was all of course
still relevant everyone still used sql
but there was something more a foot and
it wasn't just nosql
it wasn't just hadoop hadoop was the
first stage
and what i saw was that there was a
tremendous amount of white space that
was going to get created in predictive
analytics on top of all that data right
you can start by just counting things
that's a good start but you can't end
there obviously there's more business
value beyond that and there was a lot of
white space
and then on the other side where i could
see um through my consulting career in
in using python for scientific computing
and then business computing what i could
see was that cloud computing and the use
of cloud and cloud adoption in business
was absolutely going to be a game
changer um which seems you know
surprising in 2012 that one still had to
make this argument but it was absolutely
still a relatively new concept at the
time for people to rent super computers
in the cloud to do their business
processing like the crown jewels of
their analytics they were generally
keeping that very guarded in-house right
they would be they would build clusters
in-house
they wouldn't think about spinning one
up on the weekend most pieces most
businesses were not thinking that so i
saw that both of these things would come
in and dramatically disrupt what
businesses demanded of their data and
what they saw uh as their technical
computing capabilities
um and so whenever there's a new
disruption one has to ask why well why
wouldn't the incumbents why don't they
have a natural right to win why does a
disruptor have a right to win well the
reason is the incumbents were really not
loved and this is a a picture from a
report that was done in 2013 to 14 like
an investor report thing and they went
and did an mps poll on existing tools
for
predictive analytics and you know
advanced analytics so outside of your bi
stuff like tableau or whatever
people were using spss they were using
sas
and again
the data sort of speaks for itself right
whereas when they went and looked at
python based things there was a
grassroots completely invisible to most
industry analysts there's this
grassroots up
swell of things happening around python
and through my consulting again talking
to some of the most well-funded
well-capitalized uh groups in the world
which is like investment banks and hedge
funds what i could see was that
they were needing the same things that
the scientific computing people were
needing at places like procter gamble or
conical phillips and it was ultimately
around this persona of a domain expert
and
you know of course in wall street they
call them quants but the idea here is
that these domain experts um
they want just actually a few things
they want to be unencumbered in how they
do advanced analytics
they would go and get some data they
would go and try this try that they'd
plot some stuff and they could tweak
some stuff and they write some code and
they do all these different things it's
a lab bench in a room filled with lab
benches stacked high of equipment and
they're just bouncing all over the place
doing all sorts of cool stuff
then once they got something working
they wanted to quickly share that thing
and precisely that thing with their
collaborators they didn't want someone
to come in and say okay let's go rewrite
this in java we'll be back in six months
with something that's completely not
what you expect right they wanted just
to have the thing they built don't touch
it it works and they want to get someone
else to come in and take a look at it so
that rapid application development
that's actually a term right rad was the
term back in the 90s and early 2000s
kind of fell by the wayside but it's a
real concept and it empowers these kinds
of domain experts because they don't
their context and their ideas they don't
have to cross this air gap to a bunch of
cs majors that don't understand calculus
so we saw that as the thing they wanted
and the last thing was um all this
capability they wanted it in a way that
integrated with their existing
infrastructure right it couldn't have to
they they could not teleport to some
walled garden where uh the stuff all
worked and then like come back to
reality it all disappeared they needed
to speak to java or c plus or fortran or
net or whatever they really needed for
it to at least have some semblance of
integration and
the cool thing is python checks all
these boxes um you know python just
quietly gets out of your way unless you
do a lot of these different kinds of
things
i've seen
um you know geophysicists pick the stuff
up in the space of an afternoon and get
quite productive and that was the kind
of thing that really drove that
grassroots adoption and even gartner was
starting to recognize this in 2014 this
is from their magic quadrant back then
and this is before they started sticking
anaconda in the lower left-hand quadrant
so it was quite a long time ago but um
the
alex linden over there you know wrote
this up in his report he said you know
what's interesting is that the
innovative data scientists i talked to
they really favor open source
components like in python and r
but of course there's no there's no
vendor for python i guess there is a
vendor for r kind of and we're of course
a vendor for python but not the way that
sas is a vendor for sas right or math
works as a vendor for matlab so there's
no way for them to actually put it into
their magic quadrant they really
couldn't
get open source through this lens um but
they did recognize there was something
happening even back in in 2014
and and the thing that was really
interesting to me was i would go into
conferences i would go and give pi data
talks and i try to give people some kind
of a framework for understanding what
makes python different and special right
because again people would say oh is
this is this just like that ruby thing
or oh is this the
upstart competitor to r or i thought
python was just like bash you know like
all these things um but python actually
occupies a really really interesting
unique position in that it can appeal to
very different personas um and and you
can see you know python
is maybe for a lot of professional
software engineers python is the
preferred language but for many of them
it's not right for many of them they
prefer java or or c plus plus or c sharp
um but uh but if you give them python
it's it's not so weird uh not the way
that sas or matlab is weird to a
professional software engineer and
likewise when you go to an analyst right
if you give them some python if they're
only used to excel a little bit of light
vb python is like not too intimidating i
mean it's different there's a little bit
more stuff but it's not so you know
unapproachable the way that a pile of c
plus is unapproachable right so python
by actually hitting all of these
different personas
it gives
groups business groups a real uh
advantage when they started adopting
python technology so these are all just
things that i distilled again from from
sort of walking the streets and and
doing um doing consulting work with the
stuff so
that's kind of what it you know
distilling this down to then why python
why did python take over
some of these things so it's easy to
learn it's got batteries included you
can do everything from visualization and
data exploration to like web scraping
and coordinating you know a bunch of
clusters
and in the community was very very good
the community actually in python is
rather friendly and pretty welcoming and
there's one thing people talk about this
a lot but there's one thing a little
thing that people also don't appreciate
which is that the python virtual machine
itself has a whole like iceberg below
the surface level of capability to
interface with c plus plus c and fortran
that is what allows it to do things in a
high performance way so you think about
as a honda civic with mounting bolts for
like
the enterprises like warp drive right so
it's a civic but then you just like you
import numpy and pandas and like oh all
of a sudden you're getting intel and kl
right so this is the kind of thing that
that also is again not so appreciated
but to a room of geeks i'll definitely
go into this the fact that the python
interpreter the c python vm not
necessarily the most advanced vm in the
world for languages not v8 right not you
know the jvm all these things that had
uh who knows how many billions of
dollars dumped into them but the c
python vm maintained by volunteers has
this uh
under the surface abi that allows all
these high performance native libraries
to interface with it and that's one of
its
secret uh powers
so
recognize all these things ten years ago
i started uh you know the company
anaconda of course we're called
continuum analytics at the time but we
also recognized that for this to work we
needed to rebrand the community a little
bit at the time it was the scientific
python community and then i said you
know what we should probably rebrand
this a little bit to pi data because
it's python for data analysis um
obviously we used you know tools and
whatnot that were more specifically
oriented towards business data
processing so we put on this little
workshop 10 years ago at uh at the
google mountain view uh headquarters uh
and i called the pi data workshop and we
had all sorts of different people show
up who are now of course when you look
back they're they're sort of like heroes
of the ecosystem uh but but at the time
they were just our friends from the
sci-fi community um so you could have
gone for you know we charged i think 25
or 35 dollars on eventbrite for this
thing and you could have taken an
advanced numpy course from travis you
could have taken a pandas course from
west mckinney a visualization a
matplotlib course from john hunter um i
mean all of these things it was amazing
right nice actually down there you see
there's a machine learning course taught
by jacob
um and back in those days we're calling
jake von der plus jacob so that's how
old this was but it was a really good
event it was first of many it was very
popular and we definitely struck a nerve
right so since then we've seen python
dramatically accelerate adoption a lot
of really great things happen along the
way to push it
you know to increase that curve but when
you look at the stack overflow um polls
and whatnot you know numpy just numpy
itself having as much popularity as dot
net in terms of developer usage and mind
share and adoption it's absolutely
amazing um
so that's kind of how we got here
and so now stage two now enterprises
start adopting your stuff right good
news and bad news enterprises are
adopting your stuff in droves and a lot
of them have no idea what they're doing
so now what do you do right and this was
something that i even saw in 2011 or so
but but really now we're seeing where
entire the entire industry around data
data analysis um everyone's using python
and everyone has questions and everyone
has a talent shortage so what do you do
right so in this next section episode
five we're going to talk about um
what does that mean and what are the
challenges and and um you know to the
theme of data council being a no bs data
conference there's going to be um some
some straight talk in this section
so where does python live and and what
is the role of python in this era where
people are adopting ml ops
and i want to go back to this really
interesting tweet from paco nathan just
last month
um and in it he's it's a long thread i
recommend people reading it which is why
i didn't put a link to it here it's
awesome um but it's it's really great
because he talks about the difference
between frameworks and libraries and
what's the difference um and he says a
very again he doesn't mince words here
he said you know in
in professional i.t environments there's
a
tendency towards frameworks because they
allow a priesthood
to emerge around the management and the
operations of the framework
whereas libraries don't give you that so
much libraries a person just takes the
library does the thing and now they've
kind of gone off the reservation they've
done weird things but whatever it wasn't
a framework they could just load it
import it deploy it run it
but a framework you know something that
it can understand because it's sort of
this thing they have to kind of you know
operationalize it and colonize it and
turn it into a part of the priesthood so
when i started looking at how python was
actually getting used in businesses
10 years ago it was people trying to get
java developers to write python code
which doesn't work very well
because they write java in python
but then that's kind of gotten a little
better but now we're still running into
a new set of problems which is all of
the ops stuff right all the coordination
around machines and infrastructure and
and cloud and data and all these things
um
this is these are all clearly areas that
businesses have had a long history of
managing and they have opinions on how
they should be managed and those
opinions generally come up from the silo
the siloed organizational structures
here's data management here is the the
infrastructure team here is the ops team
uh and they have opinions on you know
what technologies you'd be using for
your for your management of containers
so when you look at how enterprises
adopt tech in general the structure of
the it organization defines how they
adopt it not the actual technology
itself you could build the greatest
machine learning system or library or
whatever uh in the world and when it
hits the enterprise you know people in
the kind of the mature and lagger stages
of adoption cycles um they're going to
refract that into how they look at the
world which is this three-color way
and that siloization
is going to kind of work its way back
upstream into how you think about the
architecture of your framework
and here is the problem
most of the lift that we get in building
unified frameworks around this stuff
comes from the unification comes from
the fusion comes from the fluid movement
of context between the data management
piece and the exploration piece and the
operationalization piece but as soon as
it takes it they tend to refract it into
these different components they lose all
the color in the middle
and
and uh this is a little bit this is
where the hard talk comes in what i've
seen is
most of the really big established
businesses uh their in-house i.t teams
they don't get penalized for doing wrong
things
right and this is this is sort of like
one of those like uh hard truths that
that i've seen
if you know for people who are
innovators and young startup founders
here i want to give you this bit of like
hard
fought knowledge um
it's that they can actually be wrong
perpetually wrong as long as they're not
doing worse than their peers
right and this is sort of a sharper way
of saying no one got fired for buying
ibm which of course everyone's heard but
no like really literally no one gets
fired for doing the wrong thing
and so you know that whole thing about
every morning like an antelope wakes up
in the savanna well as long as they hit
their quarterly earnings no one's budget
gets cut and so if you have to build
better products and sell better tools
into this kind of an
evolutionary landscape
what do you do
right i had a really interesting out of
lunch with the ceo of our studio a few
weeks ago and he was he was griping me
about some you know
customer conversation he was having and
they were like yeah you know they're
trying to figure out how to justify
spending money on paying for our studio
enterprise
and i said look tariff you have to
understand sometimes you'll be in a
conversation with people who can be just
wrong forever
so stop trying to convince them just
because you're right
and he just had this like almost like a
neo-red pill moment he just like
couldn't he was like oh my god you're
right they can just do that
um and this is why fundamentally why
there is an adoption curve why there is
a chasm there that chasm is a chasm of
clue right um and i don't i mean that in
the most loving way possible but that is
uh the the innovators and the the the
bleeding edge adopters they are doing
sense making on the basis of the
the substance and the fundamentals
people on the other side of the clue gap
they're doing sense making on sort of
proxy measures on adoption metrics they
see on what people are talking about on
what gartner tells them is the the the
you know thing in the upper right-hand
quadrant and i mean speed of gartner
right they have this hype cycle thing
the reason there's a hype cycle the
reason why there's this you know
inflated expectations and then a just
like a trough of uh disillusionment is
because of this gap so
the thing and this is kind of a weird uh
observation but it's something that
as an open source advocate and champion
for such a long time like something i
think about um
through open source and through
crowdsourced innovation we're going to
be delivering more and more innovation
faster kind of exponentially faster than
the world can absorb it
right so that means this curve is not
static right even as enterprise adoption
comes this way
the the fact that every single phd in
machine learning and ai out there is
working together on open source
technology to push the state of the art
faster it means this gap will just widen
and widen and when you have a wide gap
like that you know nature wears a vacuum
people will vent all sorts of crap into
the middle of it people will sell all
sorts of garbage and if you're trying to
sell good stuff in the middle of that
gap you have to be aware of the
structure of your competitive landscape
so
this is i call this sort of a
semi-permanent condition because open
source did revolutionize and transform
how ai and data science uh proceeds and
and it's really a crowdsourced movement
now right it's not gated by only what
amazon tells us is good or only what you
know sas tells us is good lots of people
are doing all sorts of cool stuff and so
this gap will continue to widen and
there's this clue gap
um
and and you know kind of coming back to
this point um about you know most of you
are probably familiar with conway's law
my corollary to that is that the kinds
of systems that will stick around
in that
uh clue gap the things that stick will
be things that conform to the budget
structure of the maintenance teams
within it not the build out teams not
the capex teams the opex teams
so if so you have to be very aware of
this dynamic because you are building
and selling all sorts of data management
frameworks and ml ops frameworks really
really think about this right ultimately
businesses are not going to well they
will shift very slowly how they're
organized internally how they organize
their budgets how those it teams report
up to the cfo those things change very
very slowly
it's really not your business to change
those things so if you want to sell into
that space you have to just be aware of
that dynamic
and the way i talked about this years
ago um was that i saw this tension that
was happening because people come to me
and they say look peter we're uh we you
know part of data science group and all
sorts of good stuff is happening but can
you help us uh deal with it somehow
because they're not getting us the tools
we need they build this one docker image
and tell us everything must run off this
blessed docker image um they won't let
us install this they won't let us
install that like but they want us to go
and deliver solutions so what are we
supposed to do
and ultimately i came to this
formulation of sort of an exploration
versus production divide because data
science uh of course you can sort of
look at that as an exploratory data
analytics activity right in the in the
style of john tukey
and then most of business it
dwells on the uh on the production side
and so production has a very different
set of concerns and and the point i want
to make with the slide is that
both there's not a wrong side here right
if you are tasked with managing
production you will absolutely uh take
this particular
point of view right you want to manage
data secure it you want a government who
has access um when you look at
infrastructure you're responsible for
the spend you're right you can't just go
and tell the cfo i don't know how much
would i spend next month call me back in
30 days right you have to actually have
some planning around this as well so
they have an unenviable problem to solve
on the production side but when you're
sitting squarely in the exploration side
and you're told no please give us ai but
no you can't buy a gpu can use this
five-year-old hp laptop right it's very
frustrating to have empathy for the
other side so i was using this kind of
framing exploration versus production
and then i realized um this isn't
actually the correct framing
the better framing is pioneers versus
settlers
so what data science as it started going
to the business and going into
enterprises the people who were go who
were adopting data science in the
2013-14-15 time frame those sorts of
folks were pioneer sort of people they
liked what was new they liked doing
cutting-edge things they're pioneers
they go into these businesses who want
to bring in innovation and everywhere in
existing solid businesses publicly you
know traded businesses that have to hit
their earnings reports
everywhere is a culture a settler
mentality right you want things stable
you want these predictable you want to
know here is the budget for innovation
please don't let innovation exceed this
line on the floor and then everything
here is very well modeled on the
spreadsheet so
in this point of view settler versus
pioneer you're solving for different
kinds of objectives you're taking a
different kind of approach to life
actually one is about fear mitigation
one is a you know the the settler folks
are about mitigating uh dangers and
they're really about how can we how can
we manage the the bias if you're
familiar in statistics with the bias
variance trade-off how do we move the
bias you know maintain to it decrease
variance and then increase that bias you
know two percent every quarter and so
it's a very very um it's an operational
way of thinking about things but it's a
very low variance kind of operating mode
and if you're a pioneer you're about oh
you're all about the variance right
you're like hey can we get more variants
and then you kind of yellow into it and
see what happens and that
is
essentially the underlying struggle
between sort of data science exploratory
groups and then the production groups it
wasn't really about are you in
production or are you doing exploratory
analysis it's really about the mentality
and the mindset of the people who are
getting involved in this stuff
and the reason to sort of talk about
this way is because it is absolutely
possible to have a pioneer mindset in
operations and in production and you can
also end up with a bunch of settler
mentality in uh exploratory areas right
so the mentality is orthogonal to the
actual activity itself
so we can talk about even i have
famously tweeted some very you know kind
of um
snarky things about exploration versus
production but i'm going to try to adopt
this frame in the future about the
different mentalities because we can
absolutely you know if we want if we all
want to keep having these kinds of
conferences and keep having jobs doing
what we're doing
data science and all the python stuff
it's got to make its way into production
but how we actually talk about the
friction how we talk about the right
ways to think about it we have to
upgrade our thinking there
and at the one one thing i think is
really at the heart of the issue um and
i'll get to this kind of in the next
section as well
the question of scale right this is the
term that's thrown about all the time
everyone talks about scale
and in the operational settler mentality
you care about understanding the scale
of the operations really an opex scaling
kind of thing you think about how do we
reduce the cost of risk or the amount of
risk that we take on um so so ultimately
even when you think about how that
how that
affects
software engineering right if you work
in-house as a software engineer at some
big company
there will tend to be
a
there'll be a tendency to adopt tools
that treat the human resources even as
fungible labor
which anyone who has done
software engineering or done coding for
fun
you know in their own time to make cool
stuff knows that it's not fungible right
no more than music or poetry is fungible
software is a deeply creative activity
and it requires a tremendous amount of
focus and flow and context and it's fun
it's joyful right joy doesn't show up on
a spreadsheet anywhere right joy just
sounds like you're going to go off and
yolo some random new tool off of mpm
that's going to blow production so
when you look at how businesses what
what business i t operationalization of
the software coding activity uh looks
like you can also say well data science
will probably end up in that mode too
unless we do something about it
right and we can't afford to let that
happen for data science because
ultimately um
i believe that
all of the things that we're doing with
these data tools they're really about
doing a scientific transformation a
computational rationalism transformation
of business right it's really digital
transformation so this stuff is by its
very nature it's science it's it's it's
high variance you cannot take this kind
of um static
settler mentality towards something
that's fundamentally scientific so
another way to think about scale is
what if we if we flip this around and
say how do we scale the power and the
impact of a single individual
right if you know we're at you know
fortune 2000 company fubar and here at
fubar we just started a data science
center of excellence and by hooker crook
we managed to hire like one of the
brightest data scientists in the world
she comes in how do we not make her rage
quit in two weeks right how do we make
her the most powerful person at the
company
how do we scale the impact and the
creativity and the genius of one person
how quickly can she go and access all
the data systems she needs to how
quickly can she go and spin up the gpu
she needs to to do a certain amount of
auto ml or something right what how
accurately can you make a prediction if
you move that fast
you know an interesting thing because
you know we're here now at the end of oh
maybe not the end but we're here in a
lull in kovid right and what was
shocking was the beginning of kovid
moderna came out and in two days they
had sequenced the genome or they had you
know they had an mrna
vaccine candidate produced in two days
in march 2020
and it was you know the fda process and
the testing all these things there are
things we need to do obviously but that
is the process that drew out for years
right so or months and months and months
so likewise in every organization every
business there's a there's a book um
uh what is it uh islands of blue is it
islands of blue and a red ocean or
something like that talk about how most
businesses have a few profit centers
everything else is just an ocean of red
ink just like everything else loses
money there's a few heroes a few heroic
little efforts or products or
initiatives that actually make all the
money all the alpha and then everything
else is just drag
right so
this question um is just sort of a
little thing to take home and think
about what would my organization do
differently how would we be different if
we were trying to optimize for the
efficacy of a single individual
and i won't get too much into this but
but the concept of
individual creativity individual genius
all of this comes down to having slack
right having a bit of space in the
system having some slack giving people
the space to be creative and
really importantly removing fear
right letting intelligence go into leaf
notes letting them give them the slack
to do the right things this is in almost
every way the antithesis of sort of
modern business management certainly
modern i.t management approaches um and
so to go back to the star wars theme
it's sort of like we started off with a
rebellion that was about a few
individuals with lightsabers and we
ended up with everyone having to
basically line up and go into a giant
star destroyer and the only way we do
anything is by driving a star destroyer
there
and really all the data signs rebels
wanted was just a better lightsaber you
know maybe a waterproof one or something
so um
so the last section what does the future
hold right if how python got started was
all this joy and creativity in the
rebels with lightsabers and then in the
middle of it you know the enterprise
shows up and says oh we have all these
star destroyers please find yourself a
seat
what does the future hold for us and um
i think of it as the return of
cybernetics and i mean that term very
precisely in the very traditional
definition of the term so
um i don't think we can allow this
incredible interesting moment to just
get lost into diffused into a sea of
just normal classic business i.t
management right we have to look at the
fact that there is going to be this
perpetual chasm between what the
innovation space is delivering faster
and faster and where businesses can
adopt kind of clue and this clue gap
again it increases over time the
lyapunov coefficient is our worst enemy
in this case so
um
i think these things will continue to be
the case like basically data scientists
will continue to be underserved the
c-suite will continue to get hammered
with messaging and hype about aia are
you doing ai yet are you doing quantum
ai are you doing quantum ah on a
blockchain right it's gonna be more more
this kind of stuff and um
uh and ultimately the um
all of the things that whatever little
islands we build uh islands of quality
things that work they're gonna get just
washed aside by this and everyone's
gonna be miserable and everyone's gonna
be suffering
and the thing that we have to do to get
around this is we have to
um
just understand what is it that gave us
this exponential innovation it's
crowdsourcing it's peer innovation peer
education peer motivation
so maybe what we should do is actually
crowdsource the education as well and
really lean into this idea that if we
want all the things that we cherish that
we hold dear and that we love if we want
those things to actually continue to be
relevant in the business context we have
to then take on as a first class concern
as a community
we have to take on the task of getting
everyone literate getting everyone up to
speed on what this really means and what
is good
so
the reason for this is because the
future that comes is the is the past
that's been right the what's pictured
here is a analog computer that was the
the
main gun targeting computer on the iowa
class battleships
and this is the origin of cybernetics
and computing uh
uh modern computing a lot of it was in
prediction systems anti-aircraft control
and like you know gun sites and things
like that very marshall in nature but
ultimately we had an interlude of 25 or
so years of transaction systems and pcs
and all this great stuff but now we're
back to people carrying about
performance again people doing vector
computing again people doing learning
algebra again in a business environment
and we're entering into era of of
connected data to
actuation to sensing and then a loop
that runs this whole thing faster and
faster and that is cybernetics um
so the future doesn't just look like ai
it's actually computational decisioning
and so it's a decision loop
um and it's it's the observe orient
decide act loop and it's about running
it faster than your competition that's
just fundamentally what it will be and
what it is
right now everyone struggles with
literally every stage of this loop
because they're still thinking about it
from a traditional it management
perspective which is you know again that
stylization of data and infrastructure
and code and this weird data science
stuff showing up in the middle right but
all of it actually is integrated in this
in this loop
um
and in order to actually manage the
whole thing you have to take a holistic
approach
fundamentally correctness
what is correct right what is a valid
test for the system it depends on what
you see as the scope of the system if
it's just a function then a function
test is sufficient but it's an entire
predictive system then the data inputs
are actually an important part of the
test
you could not change a line of code in
github and still have a system that
breaks from today to tomorrow because
the environment changed because your
training data is no longer
matches the the operational environment
right so we actually have to look at
performance the data values themselves
those are aspects of correctness and
when we think about change management
for this whole system our ability to be
agile is also an aspect of correctness
right there's no no no military on the
planet will buy a missile that goes
faster and faster once you launch it but
has no targeting system to correct when
the target moves your ability to
retarget is absolutely as critical as
your ability to get to the target in
time
so
we have to look at all of these concerns
these classical silos in one fused
system this is the future
so um i'm running a little short on time
so i put all these up at the same time
what i think of the zender cybernetics
is you've got to be respectful of the
different components of this they all
work together they're not you know but
they're somewhat orthogonal you've got
to understand in the middle
how how good is your computer and what
does a good computer look like and when
should you actually try to go and do a
distributed system
you got to understand data you got to
understand that data is almost always
the result of having some other model or
some other thing produce the data so you
got to have the whole chain of it right
um and then you have to understand your
organization right in and i'm going to
quote the author of the little prince
here he wrote there's but one variable
problem and that's the problem of human
relations you'll not get anything done
unless you're able to get all the
stakeholders on board and to understand
the stakeholders you have to understand
their budgets and their compensation
structures and there only if you map
that out can you get to success it's not
about the code it's not about how many
queries you do per second or what the
latency is in your lambda architecture
it's about actually how can the business
absorb this thing i'm trying to give
them and the thing you do is any good at
all it will be a fusion of things but
they don't really know how to fuse so in
order to actually bring about the
cybernetic age we've got to um
understand the fight we're in for we
understand why we fight which is to get
everyone in the world able to do these
kinds of things and to sustain this this
innovation path um
and uh and we have know how to fight
right we have to know what exactly are
the challenges that we'll run into and
how to talk about these challenges with
all the other stakeholders
thank you so much thanks pete and the
team putting this event on